He wrote these books,
notebooks that haven't been published
yet,
called the black books and the black
books are the documentation of his
experiments with his imagination and
what he would do is daydream like,
like a child daydreams.
He regained that faculty,
although I think with you,
and it was a faculty that has never
really disappeared and he had figures of
imagination that came to him that he
could speak with and he spoke with these
figures of imagination and documented
that over a very long period of time.
And that was originally.
That was eventually distilled into a
book called the Red Book,
which was published about three or four
years ago.
And it was a book that young regarded as
the central source from which all his
inspiration emerged.
It was sort of the way it looks to me is
that we embody a lot of information in
our action.
Right?
And our action has developed as a
consequence of imitating other people
and not only the people or the people
around us,
but of course the people around us
imitated the people who came before them
and those people in imitated.
The people who came before them and so
on so far back that it's as far back as
you can go,
and so you embody these patterns of
behavior that are extremely informative,
that you don't understand,
that are a consequence of collective
invitation across the centuries and
throw.
Then those patterns can become manifest
as figures of the imagination and those
failures of imagination are the
distillations of patterns of behavior
and so as the distillations of patterns
of behavior,
they have content and it's not you that
content.
It's you could even think about it as
content that's evolved.
Although it's culturally transmitted.
It's content that's evolved and so these
figures of the imagination can reveal
the structure of reality to you and
that's what happened with young and
that's what he described in the red book
and that was what permeated his
psychology.
Psychology.
That was based on the presupposition
that the fundamental architectural
structures of religious belief.
We're not pathological,
not deceitful,
not protective in some delusional sense
against the fear of death,
but quite the contrary.
The very stories that enabled us to move
forward as confident human beings in the
face of chaos itself and it's
conceivable,
I think perhaps probable that nothing
more important conceptually happened in
the 20th century than that because it
was the first time post enlightenment
that Ab rapprochement between the
intellect and the underlying religious
archetipal occurred.
You have in the capacious intellect of
young and the same thing happened to
some degree with piaget.
The religious domain and the factual
domain were brought back together and
the fact of young's enduring and
increasing popularity and influence,
I would say is a direct consequence of
that.
Now some of his work was spun off into
the new age and the new age is a very
optimistic and naive movement.
It's predicated on the idea that you can
do nothing say,
but follow your bliss and that will take
you ever hire to enlightenment.
And that's not the union idea at all.
The union idea is that what you most
need will be found where you least want
to look.
So there's this story.
King Arthur,
there's this story of King Arthur the.
They're all in round table,
right?
King Arthur and his knights,
they're all equals.
They're all super ordinary,
but they're all equals and they go off
to look for the holy grail from the holy
grail.
Grail is the container of the redemptive
substance,
whatever that is might be the cup the
Christ used at the last supper might be
a cellist that was used to capture his
blood on the cross,
right when he was pierced by a sword.
The stories differ,
but that's the holy grail and the holy
grail is lost.
That's the redemptive substance and the
knights of King Arthur go off to search
for the holy grail and but they don't
know where to look.
So where do you look when you don't know
where to look for something you need
desperately,
but I've lost.
Well,
each of the nights goes into the forest
at the point that looks darkest to him,
and that's union psychoanalysis in a
nutshell.
It's like that which you fear and avoid
that which you hold in contempt,
that which disgusts you and that you
avoid.
That's the gateway to what you need to
know.
There's nothing new agey about that,
that's for sure.